so you have a podcast called literally
and you've had to book guests and I'm
just curious who made you work the
hardest to get them on your podcast very
good question very good well the ones
who are making me work the hardest are
the ones who are still not on the
podcast
um I've been chasing Bruce Springsteen
but you know what I'm going to give it
up to Howard Stern
um he got Bruce
um
you know
they're they're either really really
really difficult
or they're really really really Robert
Downey Jr is proving very difficult and
he's an old friend I'm gonna have to
have Stern words with him when I get him
on the podcast
Iron Man right behind you there you have
an Iron Man uh yeah it's Robert daddy Jr
let's go with that answer most difficult
uh I will say that um Howard Stern is an
amazing amazing interviewer but I'm
gonna I'm gonna say that he gets to
cheat because he gets like five hours
with people I'm joking about the time
he's so good at his job but he also gets
so much time with people he does yeah
and you know in theory we have as much
as we want we don't do that much I I
find that um
about 43
minutes to you know an hour or The Sweet
Spot for for our interviews I think uh I
I agree with you
um if someone is actually you have had
an amazing career in Hollywood but if
someone's a young person has never seen
anything you've done what is the first
thing you want them watching and why it
depends on how old they are right
um like if they're super young and I'm
super blessed to have fans of all ages
so you know teenagers should watch The
Outsiders
um but if you're gonna watch The
Outsiders make sure it's The Outsiders
the complete novel
not not The Outsiders
um
you know college age folks should watch
Parks and Recreation
um
if it's date night you should watch
About Last Night movie
um if you're in for a thriller watch bad
influence and gotta watch The West Wing
gotta watch Tommy Boy
of course this is what this is what I'm
talking about when when uh when I was
given the chance to talk with you I'm
like of course I'm gonna F and do this
I'm like you've been in so many things
that I love you know um but another
thing is that you it is very hard for
anyone to be in one successful show in
Hollywood and yet you've been in a few
you know Parks and Rec
um West Wing as you mentioned recently
uh Lone Star you know 9-1-1
um what is it like actually
um have you ever thought about playing
the lottery because it's really hard to
do what you're doing you know I I feel
like I have been playing the lottery
right and and and doing okay
um
yeah I I I'm so fortunate I don't know
if I if he had told me when I started
out as a young actor that that it would
turn out the way it has I would have
believed it
um
and uh I just
I'm just super grateful and you know I
think a lot of it is
um
I think I have a good I have a good
ticker you know I I I think I I know a
good story when I read it
um I try to work with people who I
admire and you know who who you know
you're always going to be funny when
you're with Amy Poehler
you know or Chris Farley or David Spade
um and you're always going to make a
good drama when you're working with Ryan
Murphy and into my near so It's a
combination of things and there's also a
little bit of luck oh no completely I've
had this conversation with people people
don't realize you can have an amazing
script and it doesn't work on the screen
and other times you might have something
that's only okay and all of a sudden
it's this amazing movie you know you
absolutely never know you you never know
I mean you know when you have something
good but somehow you know you can fumble
the bags the kids like to say
um and you know I we knew making West
Wing
we're making something special when we
were making Tommy Boy
we had no idea that it would become what
it's become I I was I had a conversation
with Jonah Hill the other day who I
think is an amazing actor and super
funny and and I was like tell me what
movies you like and he's like well my
favorite movie of all time is Tommy Boy
I said that's really nice because no no
my favorite movie of all time
is Tommy Boy I was like wait a minute
you work with Martin Scorsese you're
telling me Tommy Boy is your favorite
you just never know it also could be
when he watched it in his life it might
have been one of those things you know
you know yeah for sure it's it's always
about what you see and when you see it
it that's a that's a big thing you're
absolutely right jumping into why I get
to talk to you today
um what was it about this story and
script that said I want to do it besides
getting paid to play with the dog
well being paid to play with a dog is is
a great way to run your career I mean
it's like let's just be real
um I know actors who picked their movies
bit Adam Sandler picked his he is like
where do I want a vacation I'm gonna set
my movie there so yeah that kind of
stuff goes into it
um but but really
I love a good dog movie
I love um a tear jerker I love a movie
that's going to make you cry I I as it
just is a film goer
and the father-son
Dynamic gets me every time whether it's
on the super serious like Ordinary
People or great Santini or something
like this is something about families
um that I really respond to and this had
all three of them also there is
something nice to be making like uh
something life affirming and
heartwarming you know it's the kind of
you know I like I mean listen everyone
enjoys these kinds of films for sure and
they're they're super hard to do
um to hit that Bullseye of feel good is
really really hard to to do and I I and
this movie I think really does it um
it's something everybody can watch
um
you know to to sit and with
any age group people from any Walk of
Life and everybody is going to have the
same
reaction is is really really rare and
I've seen how people react to this movie
and
it just it just delivers I I think
mostly it's because the dog is so great
he's a great eye he's the Daniel
Day-Lewis of of dog actors great of
course I listen when I think of dog
movies I just think of John Wick 3 with
Halle Berry and the dogs and what they
did uh completely different acting
obviously that's a very different that's
more stunt performing but very this is
more emotive it's it's you know it's my
left paw
that's very good
um is it nice the movie's obviously
playing on Netflix is it nice to not
have to worry about the opening weekend
box office and just know that anyone you
know what I mean yeah listen I I love
that
you know there's not that kind of
pressure
on on a movie on any movie
um and I love this I love being on
Netflix for that reason everybody's
gonna see it everybody watches Netflix
everybody's gonna see it and you know
that and that's and that's that's great
I I I'm super excited it's a perfect
perfect home for this I I absolutely
agree um are you a dog or a cat person
and has it changed through your life it
has changed through my life I started as
a cat person I had two cats
um and then my uh young first son was
classified allergies to cats so that was
the end of cats then we got dogs and uh
we've always had dogs ever since I have
four dogs
um right now I have um Daisy Oscar Owen
and Bella and who is the one that begs
the most at the table for food
all of them and they but they all have
different styles right
they they they've they realize that not
all of them can just blatantly beg so I
have one that kind of Co poses in the
corner in hopes that you notice I have
one that hits me with the Paw and I I
have one that sits like a good little
dog so they all have their different
Acts but they all just want the bacon
because of my schedule we have cats and
um uh and it is interesting how each one
begs a different way yeah for sure cats
you know cats are the best they're like
the way they they're like I love you
maybe I don't love you I like they they
give love and then they withhold love
and it's it's very compelling oh without
a doubt um how do you actually you've
done so many different roles I'm gonna
jump backwards actually yeah what did
you think that you could make it as an
actor and pay rent with just acting well
I was super lucky that I never had to
face that because I started acting when
I was living at home
so and that's a big thing it's not to be
overlooked it's a big deal for actors to
go can I support myself
um I never had to do that because I I
started acting at 13 professionally at
13. so I was bringing in money while I
had a roof over my head
um although I did have a period from 15
to 18 where I didn't work and I thought
I was a uh you know I was going to be a
flash in the pan and I sort of had to
figure out what I was going to do with
my life and I was decided I was going to
go to law school and I applied to
college and I did all those things and
on my 18th birthday I got The Outsiders
and so the rest was you know kind of
History definitely have to touch on
Wayne's World and how that came in in
your life uh speaking of cats
um and when uh when uh when that came in
your life uh because that was a big role
for you at the time oh yeah um you know
I grew up watching Saturday Night Live
everything I knew about comedy I learned
from SNL
um I got to host it three times and it
was my relationship with Lauren Michaels
through hosting that got me in Wayne's
World because
um Mike and Dana had never done a movie
Mike and Dana didn't even know that
there were marks on the floor that you
stood so the camera could record you
because they don't have those on SNL so
I mean they were really green
and um so I remember Lauren saying that
you know to have somebody who knew what
a movie was
was going to be important and and then
that started my relationship with Mike
and that led to of course the Austin
Powers movies
and then you know my continued
relationship with Lauren led to Tommy
Boy so that kind of little SNL corner of
my career is something I'm I'm really
proud of because I love just being a
part of that Legacy even in the small
part that I am if someone has never seen
your episodes of SNL is there one sketch
you're particularly proud of
yeah I think when I play Arsenio Hall is
is pretty when I play Arsenio Beckman is
pretty funny I love that one
um
geez there's the the the church lady one
is up sprockets I remember meeting Mike
Myers and him going do you want to do
Wayne's World or do you want to do
sprockets I was like I want to do
sprockets because it's just so weird
um but they were all really good I'm
super proud of of those snls oh you know
sometimes you just get lucky and we
those are three really strong episodes
uh you've obviously done again many many
roles uh what do you think was the
hardest one that you prepped for what
was the most you prepped for one of your
roles and which role was the hardest for
you to like let go of after filming
wrapped for sure the hardest was
um
Stephen King's The Stand
um I played Nick Andros who doesn't
can't hear can't speak
I had to learn American Sign Language
um I just because I had no dialogue in
the entire
miniseries
um you've got to find
it it just required a lot of work that
for sure was the hardest
um
I think letting go when I was done
I mean there are characters you you want
to just PL I wish I could be Eddie Nero
from Californication
like in my real law I just love I love
that character so much
um because it's so outrageous
um but I also think
Chris Trager
in parks and rec is very similar to me
and and uh I can feel myself falling
into
my Chris Traeger patter from time to
time I literally
and feel it happening uh I I definitely
want to touch on Parks and Rec because I
love that show uh I just love it um have
you noticed that with because you know
when it was on it was popular but it
wasn't the way it became more especially
with streaming have you noticed the
power of streaming with that show
specifically oh
in parks and rec for sure it was never a
hit
um and it's become
you know what it's become because people
caught up with it because of streaming
if streaming wasn't around Parks and Rec
would not be what it is today but even
The West Wing which obviously was a hit
um continues to have an audience today
that weren't even alive when it came out
because of of streaming so I love I love
streaming because it used to be if you
did something that you liked it was gone
forever
and if you didn't have the DVD or VHS
you were out of luck now you could find
almost anything I did a show called the
grinder that I is my favorite comedy
I've ever been in
that's I'm gonna say it again the
grinder my favorite comedy I've ever
been in
one season on Fox and was done but you
can get it on I think Hulu and it you
know I love that people can still find
it streaming's great for that uh I agree
and they make movies that might not
normally be made or or that are tougher
to get made but on that note I need to
stop I'm just going to say
um seriously uh pleasure to talk with
you I wish you nothing but the best
thank you so much this was awesome let's
do it again
sir anytime um thank you and good luck
with booking uh Downey Jr